foreign
we're back let's go out to North
Carolina and talk to the great and
wonderful Jackie what's up Jackie hi Dr
John thanks for having me of course
thanks for calling what's up yeah
um so my husband and I we have been
married 19 years
um High School sweethearts we have five
kids
um
but last week he revealed to me that
about 15 years ago when he was in the
military
that he had cheated on me numerous times
during his first two deployments
overseas
um
to that time I mean we were having
issues
and someone had actually came to me and
said that he had cheated on me
um I confronted him then about it and he
looked me dead in the eye and was like
no that's not true
um and I believed him you know because I
I thought I knew him I thought he was a
man of integrity and
um but yeah so
I'm I feel like I'm at a Crossroads I
can either choose to leave and I know
what that looks like
um or I can choose to forgive him and
you know try to rebuild and that's I I
don't know what that looks like I don't
if if that's something I do choose I
don't know how to do that
oh man
I'm sorry this happened
ma'am thank you
it's like buying a house and you realize
15 years later they didn't put in a
sewer pipe or something right and you're
like right I mean that's just been going
in the backyard yeah yep yeah yeah I
feel yeah it I feel deceived
um for you know so many years that's not
a feeling that's a fact that happened
yeah right right and then if you're like
me I'm wondering well what else did you
not tell me exactly
that you need to tell me like this is
the time just get it all out
um that's like you're asking you're
asking a liar to tell you the truth now
right exactly yeah yeah
and of course he said no no no not at
all yeah exactly yeah
very remorseful about it um but that
doesn't you know change the fact that
I'm hurt and betrayed and
I just feel like our whole majority of
our marriage is a lie like none of it
was real and that I think is something
to be careful of because that's not true
okay okay
the picture you had is different
right but he did show up when your mom
got sick
okay he did come to the hospital five
times
right right right he did fill in the
blank so those things are all true and
they're all real and so burning the
whole thing to the ground everything's a
lot it's not those things actually
happened because you were there and you
saw it you witnessed it
and
he did look you dead in the eye and say
I promise you and he lied
both are true
and so kind of like I think there's
gonna be a lot of both hands moving
forward and your temptation is going to
be to go to Absolute
there's a ton of both ands moving
forward okay so this I I
don't have
I don't have an easy answer for you okay
um this came up a lot in 2018 and 2019.
okay when the metoo stuff happened
and people who were married
had two or three kids together or loved
their husband he was a great husband he
did all the right things
and then it was like wait a minute back
in college you that was sexual assault
right or you raped me back like you got
me all drunk and wait a minute right and
so there was this all of a sudden this
this thing dropped in the middle of
people's homes which is who you are
right this second and my God you would
have gone to jail if you had done what
you did back then now
right
and
I
I don't know that there's another path
other than this
um
and if if anyone's got some wisdom reach
out to me on on Instagram you can just
DM me if you're a therapist and you've
got some a different path
but you have a choice to make
and it's very binary
I leave or I Stay
I leave I'm a single mom with five kids
and we figure out what that looks like
right right stay
everything is new
that's it
and if I stay
I am making the choice to work as hard
as bloody hell as I can
to incorporate that not forget it you
can never forget it but to incorporate
what happened into our marriage and move
forward
because if you choose to stay and choose
to put that in that arrow in your quiver
to shoot him whenever he's late to
something or whatever he whatever then
the whole thing burns down
right yeah that's I definitely don't
want to yeah participate in that or you
know be passive aggressive towards him
or you know constantly throw it in his
face when he does something you know
wrong can I tell you what I'm hearing on
you and you can tell me if I'm crazy
okay I hear that you want to stay but
you want to want to leave
yes I always I've I've always been that
that person that was like I would never
if you know if my husband ever cheated
on me like that would be it like there
wouldn't I would walk away and now it's
I mean if he were to do this last week
like if he would have cheated on me last
week or a month ago I feel like it would
be so much easier too
walk away you'd be in the same spot
you're in right now ah yeah it's it's
not so cool to be so tough it's like the
person without kids are like if I had
kids oh you don't know right I mean we
all have these proclamations till they
happen yes yes yeah that's exactly what
it was approximation and I want you to
trust Jackie not this Macho image of
Jackie that you were projecting to the
world
and you're going to probably vacillate
and there's gonna be days that you
really wake up and the sun is shining
and you're making breakfast and he comes
in and you lean in
and there's going to be times you pick
up a dirty shirt and you overcome with
rage right okay right yeah there's going
to be days you want to sit down across
the table and say I want to hear about
every single girl what she looked like
what her name was where y'all were
there's gonna be no I don't I don't want
that yeah not yet that day will come not
yet but I promise you it'll come and
there's going to be days when you just
want to say hey that was 15 years ago
we're different we got five kids we have
our home here in the states we're moving
on and
the challenge is is going to be sitting
down with a
an architect in your case a marriage
counselor
and y'all designing and building what's
going to come because your marriage as
you knew it is over
right right
and you ought to decide are we gonna
build something new and by the way he
has to be in and on it too
no he's fully committed I mean no he
thinks he is yeah he thinks he is right
right yeah how can I address that I
don't know you just rolled the stone
away and the dragon just came out so he
thinks he's all in he doesn't fully know
yet
true what what brought this out what
brought the story
um so we we've just been like just
sharing things
um with each other just kind of like
self just like self-reflecting and you
know there we we had some really bad
times
um kind of early on in our marriage and
just talking about like how we got over
that and you know
drinking was involved on his part and
um I had shared that I had felt like
maybe he did something because I always
felt like when we were around people
there were Whispers I felt like they
were they were talking about me oh so
some of his some of his combat buddies
knew
yeah oh yeah for sure okay so
and nobody told me well I mean one
person did but they weren't close so I
you know just kind of took them at face
value and do you see that that that
that's where you're gonna have to go
because that's not just betrayal 15
years ago
yeah that is you made me the laughing
stock right oh yeah no I told him how
foolish I must have looked that's it you
know that's it yeah yeah
laughs
yeah I guess yeah yeah
it's a lot and there's that other voice
it was like oh my gosh it was 15 years
ago yeah that yeah you know who I was 15
years ago an idiot yeah exactly we were
we were definitely different people then
I mean that doesn't excuse the fact no
it doesn't excuse anything you know but
we were you know we were we were
different people then we've definitely
grown and matured together
um but yeah it's it's still
hurts a lot well yeah so I guess what
the best I could tell you is this
um
I would make a decision and it sounds
like I know what your decision is but I
would make a decision that I'm at least
interested in
meeting with an architect or not
if you're done you're done if you're out
you're right I don't hear that on you at
all no
no I don't think so I don't think so
okay you have to get let Jackie off the
hook
Jackie is not weak Jackie is not a
coward Jackie is not a wimp Jackie is
not a pushover
for staying
okay yeah he's very strong
yeah and that's something I've always
kind of prided myself on is you know I'm
strong I'm independent especially you
know when he was in the military and he
was gone you know I was holding things
down and you know how much infidelity
runs in in those circles and you aren't
going to be that woman here we are yeah
yeah so in the same way that you are
trying to work through the man he was 15
years ago
also work through this imaginary you
know pseudo Wonder Woman that you'd
created that wasn't real it's in the
past okay let that rock yeah this is
Jackie right now facing reality I've got
five kids I love this man I love who he
has become I love the husband he is and
God I want to kill him for what he did
15 years ago and for the subsequent lie
that that rippled through our marriage
for the last 20 years
both are true
okay
and I
uh
sometimes speaking is very hard
and I I it can be immoralist it can be a
cowardice issue whatever I tend to think
of it as a tools issue and that's
probably me being soft on people but
such it is
um
he may not know or have the ability to
sit in a room and hurt somebody like he
hurt you again
but he might be able to write it down
okay and so I would ask him
I want you to spend some time
writing out preference be handwritten
but you can type it if you'd like
anything else I need to know because you
embarrassed me
yeah and you broke my heart yeah
and I know it's not but it feels like my
entire life is built on a lie
and so I need you to ride out for me
type it out for me what else do I need
to know
if anything else any other cheating any
other office romances any other
shirtless photos you sent to somebody I
need to know every bit of it
and write it out and then write me the
letter and I'm going to read it and I'm
going to decide what's next
okay and I'm kind of 50 50 right now if
I'm super honest with you okay I've got
buddies in the military and I've worked
with enough folks in the military that
things happen overseas then people come
back and it's it's a hard toggle because
I'm not there right right yeah um yeah
no for sure no excuses but right and the
other 50 is that's just people who cheat
are people who cheat
right yeah yeah you're either cheater or
not right
okay yeah it sounds like I've got um and
then if you read that letter and you say
I've made an appointment you need to be
there
and we're gonna go figure it out and I
think you tell the counselor you just
told me I found out of some pretty
um Insidious
infidelity multiple women
um
over several deployments and then here
we are and we need to figure out how to
build something new
and expect yourself to feel
schizophrenic
okay yeah I mean I already do yeah I
know I know but but people are caught
off guard by how weirdly turned on they
feel in certain moments
okay and then how weirdly turned off
they are in certain moments
okay all right that's good to know that
because
that's getting weird for a second
and this is like a this is like a
teaching for people listening okay okay
there's a very weird oh I'll show him in
a very erotic way sometimes
okay
fair or not fair
Fair okay and then you get really pissed
at that you feel like that
and then there is also like
I will never sleep with that man again
until the end of time and then I'm gonna
add a year to that right yes and then
your over will come by this is happening
right now right and it's this toggle and
you don't know who you are anymore
yeah that's that is all true and that's
exactly yeah it's what I've been
experiencing this past week okay
and you feel super close that he told
you this deep dark secret and it was
romantic and by the way you asked for it
and also I want to kill you and bury you
in the backyard and I don't think they
would ever find your body all the same
time yes
it's jarring
okay
that's the foundation that's been
cracked
so give yourself a lot of Grace do a lot
go get a special Journal
okay
and just put the new Twin Towers you can
call it whatever you want but right okay
give yourself permission to be like oh
my gosh I haven't wanted to be with him
it's actually this bad in years and in
the very following hour I will never and
then the very following hour I've never
been this mad and never falling out I
miss him so bad I wish I wish you would
just come home and hug me right now keep
record of those things because they're
gonna they're gonna they're important
for you to process as you move forward
that's grief what you're experiencing
just that oh that tight away for sure
yeah for sure
I hate that for you I'm sorry Jackie
yeah yeah no thank you thank you for for
talking with me this is it's been really
helpful have you told any of your
friends
I have not told anybody you're actually
the first person that I've discussed
this with all right so um
an earlier caller unfortunately had a
similar situation but not really but
sort of
um
I think you're before you call a
counselor
after you sit with your husband answer
that letter I think you sit down with
two or three women that you really trust
and you let them know
yeah I think I would tell them I'm not
asking for y'all's wisdom right now I
just need to say this out loud to some
people I trust that I know like that
will keep it quiet
right okay and there's something about
saying it out loud that takes it from
being surreal to this is happening to me
right now yes
is that fair
Jackie one more thing one more thing ah
okay
I want you to put a very
dramatic in concrete and stone not even
a concrete and stone this moment that
you're feeling right now okay
you have a default setting that rolls
off to okay cool that's great that's
great that's great that's great that's
great cool cool all right whenever you
feel uncomfortable
you roll into it let's just move on
if you bury this it will come back and
Destroy no I I know that yeah I know you
know it but you I'm trying to you have
to know it enough to do something about
it I know my gummy candies will kill me
man it's like ass all right that's
that's a problem for future John this is
a problem for right now Jackie okay yeah
cool
yep because I can hear you doing it to
me all right
literally I I love it I love it I love
it I'm in very intimate space with you
right now and I get that but I want you
just to be cautious when you people ask
me like what do you mean by awareness
and curiosity this is it right here when
you feel your body start to go okay cool
all right cool cool cool that's when you
go nope my body's trying to run we're
not gonna run this time we're standing
firm
yeah so I have to get used to being
uncomfortable and that is the next
little while of your life
yeah
Fair
that's fair yeah I'm so sorry this
happened I'm so sorry this happened
and I'm so grateful for you being brave
because because of your bravery this
conversation is going to help a whole
bunch of people and to feel a little bit
less nuts
just crazy when these things happen just
it completely unspools people and so um
thank you for being brave